vaccination means freedom from fear  20 years ago governments from all over  the world joined forces  with the private sector so that vaccines  could become a  universal right for all humankind  in 2000 10 million children worldwide  were dying before their fifth birthday  this number has been cut to half  the european union is proud to be part  of this story  we must keep fighting polio the human  papilloma virus  and many other killer diseases  yet the challenge of this pandemic is  unprecedented in modern times  the development of vaccines has been a  remarkable  team effort but we will need an  even greater effort to deliver them to  every  village of this world and we have to  prove  the safety and the efficacy of those  vaccines  especially in the face of growing  vaccine skepticism  and disinformation campaigns  and the message is clear vaccination  is about self-protection and solidarity  we are in this together and we will win  this fight  against this pandemic together